here we go
hey there nothing more 90s than that one
second dude
a [ __ ] recorder
hey guys
she's got a mock turtleneck on ah
sir
90s
you on a razor scooter
what's your favorite show friends again
this is my brother peter mom and dad
that's me that's literally just how i
look jesus christ dude i literally look
like that kid right there unbelievable
wore the same [ __ ] baggy as [ __ ] jeans
dude that's me bro
that's what they want you to think
that's you because they want you to
relate to it well guess what [ __ ]
kid's guide to the internet you did it
we're going to be showing our friends
andrew and lisa the basics of the
internet and we thought you might want
to come along it'll be cool now here's a
little background when we installed i
murdered a computer i got there's a
little background involved it's true
everybody had their own tasks to do it
was a lot of work but it was really
worth it wow i mean you know it was a
lot of work but i was really worth it
what would just happen did you make a
noise oh no i didn't hear
well it was a lot of work but it was
really worth it not a lot of work you
know
you hit on
is that it right
now that i've gotten on the internet i'd
rather be on my computer than doing just
about anything it's really i mean
they're actually that's a good thing
dude wow in the 90s that was the [ __ ] oh
good he's gonna get a lot of work done
[ __ ] closes the door be out be out
after dinner
[ __ ] just spanking off to some
[ __ ] just figuring it out just online
figuring it out you know just [ __ ]
out just in in his dad's office just
spanking just
figuring it out you know
just figuring out everything all the
emotion exploring and i don't mean the
[ __ ] world wide web just [ __ ] yeah
i'll be right out dude whenever the
internet happened in the beginning i
would [ __ ] first of all i aimed it up
aim dude alicatz27 or whatever the [ __ ]
my username was
um
and uh
i would just go in chat rooms what's up
i'm out
haha
anyone like cars i'm outbound sup who's
your favorite ninja turtle bam leave
before they even answer dude i don't
give a [ __ ] what's alicat 27 going to
say
who gives a [ __ ] what you gonna say
raphael i'm out already
age sex location just pop in one room
got a boner leave
do you know what i mean
anyone out there looking for some fun
bam leave before the [ __ ] 50 year old
man replies yes
bro i'm out you know but i would do the
[ __ ] internet and then i would do my
mom every time it was unbelievable she
would ask me how to do the internet and
i would sign her on to aol and it would
[ __ ] be
um
[Applause]
welcome you've got mail
and then she'd be like thanks i'd be
like so that's your mailing thing and
then okay cool and then head away okay
and then and then how do i okay and then
this and then okay and there's no it's
in the icon just drag it over okay
you got it yeah i'd leave every time i
left i walk down the hallway i think oh
[ __ ] christopher
bro when i say my blood boiled because i
know it was over dramatic and didn't and
she didn't need to be doing that now of
course did that create deeper issues for
me yes okay
but i would be like mom it's fine i'll
walk back in what did i do okay so what
did i do
you look you just minimized it that's
all you did all you got to do is click
out over here okay that's it she
minimized it dude if moms weren't
minimizing pages what else the [ __ ] were
they doing in the 90s by mistake oh [ __ ]
christopher oh what did i do from the
other room and me just goddamn
[ __ ]
okay coming
can you leave so i can [ __ ]
figure it out and i don't mean the world
wide web
gave us a whole world of exciting new
possibilities so i guess this is a story
of how it changed our lives maybe it
will yours too i mean this kid grew up
to be a [ __ ] mass murderer just and
now i can't even get offline no matter
what
it's really great
all i do is watch nature killing nature
i saw a video of a bear eating a yak the
other day and the yak couldn't have been
more than three months old
all i do is look at the computer
i really su the only the only instagram
handle i subscribe to is nature is metal
to the internet
take a spin now you're in with the
techno set you're going surfing on the
internet
i didn't know that was coming
that was the most jingliest jingle of
all time dude
i mean jesus christ that makes bad up
seem like a song from brian mcknight
unfucking real dude
that makes the [ __ ]
men men men men men men men looks like
it's written by [ __ ] bach
are you [ __ ] me that was the most
jingliest jingle ever take a spin what
the [ __ ] did it say the most ninety [ __ ]
of all time let's see what i've got here
we go dude take a spin on the internet
unreal dude it's really cool the
internet here we got a whole world of
exciting new possibilities so i guess
this is a story of how it's grew up to
be a mass murderer maybe it will yours
he's on see no evil there's a special of
him on see no evil take a spin now
you're in with the techno set you're
going surfing on the internet
you're going surfing on the internet
braille dude unbelievable dude that is
unbelievable oh my god that's the song i
want to walk down walk down to when i'm
getting married
oh my god dude that's what i'm getting
done dude chris is going to come down
like [ __ ]
told you we installed the internet on
our computer not [ __ ] me dude this is
how i'm coming down
you're going to see me walking down with
my [ __ ] that i'm not even going with my
mom i'm walking down by myself this is a
story of that's it i'm walking down go
oh here he comes
who did he shave or did he keep a five
o'clock shadow
and then
now you're in with the techno set you're
going surfing on the internet and then
pointing to the [ __ ] guy and being
like i do
you going surfing on the internet wow
the most ninety [ __ ] i've ever seen in
my life dude george hamilton looked at
that video and [ __ ] fainted that's
how 90s it is [ __ ] inaccess saw that
and they go we got to give up music
that's how [ __ ] 90s it is i swear to
god duran duran saw that all four of
them [ __ ] themselves that's how 90s it
was that's 80s but no honestly insane
dude the ninja turtles goes you know
what not cowabunga that's what they did
it's the most 90 [ __ ] i've ever seen in
my life
as rich told you we installed the
internet on our computer nothing more
90s than a guy named rich too this is
all unbelievable dude
a short time ago and i haven't been able
to get the kids off it ever since not
only do they play the typical computer
games that all the kids enjoy but their
curiosity for learning has skyrocketed
peter is constantly quoting sports
statistics and he can tell you the best
surfing spots around the globe not to
mention the improvement
is great so basically you just made him
a rain man
peter can tell you any statistic in
baseball and where the best surfing
spots are and he's just like
malibu
frank thomas had a 420 slugging
percentage in
1990
last year
kangaroo junior had a [ __ ] 320
slagging percentage last year
surfing on the internet braille
and dashes too
having the internet in our home has had
a great impact on our lives rich people
the stock market and our investments and
i'm able to pay the bills every time it
used to take me and the kids are
improving in their grades and
communication skills which makes me
happy as i would sure like them to go to
college someday oh
dude you gotta be [ __ ] [ __ ] me
rich
which makes me happy because i would
sure like to them for them to go to
college one day dude college existed
before [ __ ] aol
they could have still gone dude
my son's gonna be a regular doogie
houser
now
dude that's how it should have been the
doogee hazard theme so it should have
been me doing that
[Music]
crazy
[Music]